le dépistage c'est un kit que vous allez
demander à votre médecin traitant et
c'est un test que vous allez réaliser
chez vous avec un recueil de vaucelles
qui permettra de détecter si a du sens
ou pas dans vos selles une fois qu'on a
détecté s'il ya du sens donc vous faites
ce test
le résultat va être envoyée à votre
médecin traitant et à vous même et ça va
détecter non pas si vous avez un cancer
mais si vous avez du sang dans les
selles et si vous avez du sang dans les
selles ça veut dire qu'il faut faire un
examen complémentaire pour savoir
pourquoi vous saignez et dans quels cas
dans ce cas là on va faire une
coloscopie
la coloscopie c'est un examen un petit
peu invasif incertain une petite caméra
qu'on passe pour arriver pour voir dans
l'intestin voir si vous avez un polype
et le but c'est que le polype si jamais
il saigne peut être prélevée et on sait
qu un polype qui saigne peut avoir des
signes de malignité et si ce polype est
haute et ça vous permet de prévenir
l'arrivée d'un cancer donc ce test et
des scies et aidés destinés à toute la
population
après 50 ans donc vous allez recevoir
une invitation par labrecque pour le
dépistage donc justement de ce cancer
colorectal et si le test est positif
vous allez être invité à faire une
coloscopie ou ne fait pas de coloscopie
à titre systématique
la coloscopie est quand même un acte un
petit peu invasif donc on fait une
coloscopie à ty systématique uniquement
si on a eu des antécédents dans sa
famille de cancer du côlon